marqué par la catastrophe il redoute
encore le pire il ya beaucoup de gens
qui sont pas partis à caux qui est
attendre la suite qui attendent après
élection qui s'interrogent sérieusement
s'ils vont continuer à vivre ici
s'ils sont pas plus protégés xo jeu
dangereux qui nous menacent leur
mettrais nous chercher l'usure la voie
ferrée est loin d'être en parfait état
rails et traverses endommagés sans
compter le clou qui ment et encore des
produits dangereux
il passe quatre à cinq fois par semaine
sur cette voie ici des convois de gaz
propane
deux ans plus tard en pleine campagne
électorale lac-mégantic cherche à se
faire entendre
aux traumatismes subis s'ajoutent
frustration et déception pour la
population le grand enjeu électoral ici
c'est la voie de contournement faut
qu'ils me disent on va vous la
construire votre voie de contournement
puis palladien la 2 3 1 est fait sur
seconde année quand vient le passage des
wagons pétrole doit reprendre dans
quelques mois les en attendant à chaque
jour
la proximité des convois est un rappel
de la catastrophe à quelques pas chez
lui pierre latulippe cherche à
comprendre a été dévastée qu'aujourd'hui
on n'a pas seulement 400 x man
inquiétant pour l'instant c'est sur la
pointe des pieds que les candidats à
pass à lac mégantic et même leurs
pancartes sont moins nombreuses que
celles des maisons avant il a craint que
j'ai que plusieurs de la population ses
comptes en banque en plus dans l'oubli
alors ce qu'on soit reste un engagement
plus ferme des partis politiques
dans une des rares circonscription
détenue au québec par les conservateurs
seul le npd s'est engagé à réaliser la
voie de contournement dont le coût très
approximatif aussi entre 50 et 100 75
millions de dollars
je pense que les gens soient pas au foot
ils vont voter pour le casier pour le
parti qui vont prendre l'engagement
clair par rapport à profondément c'est
vital pour la réparation morale mentale
psychologique la population près de 1000
personnes ont déjà quitté la ville
depuis la tragédie
mais les 5000 qui reste centre que leur
vote pourrait avoir un impact sur leur
destinée
ici marc godbout radio canada lac
mégantic